[Music]
hello there morty is the latest fighter
to join the multiverses roster with him
comes a bunch of new moves to master
each a reference to the rick and morty
show today we are looking at the origins
of morty's moveset if you're new to rick
and morty prepare for some weird sights
and if you're a fan let's take a trip
down memory lane oh and of course there
will be rick and morty spoilers
we have to start with the plumbus the
all-purpose household device a running
gag in the tv show is to never explain
what a plumbus actually does even though
you can spot it in the background of
many scenes everyone has a plumbus in
their home but thanks to
interdimensional cable tv we know how
it's made first they take the dingle bop
and they smooth it out with a bunch of
shleem they take the dingle bop and they
push it through the grumbo where the
fleeb is rubbed against it then a salami
shows up and he rubs it and spits on it
and the plubus and grumbo are shaved
away
that leaves you with a regular old
plumbus i always wondered how uh
plumbuses got made the next move you'll
see often is morty's huge arm the
origins of armory let's go this move is
taken from episode two of season three
where morty becomes spine eater an
apocalyptic fighter rick creates this
device which takes muscle memory from
unalive fighters and gives it to marty
the arm then takes over and smashes
everything to pieces including that
device that's why he only has one arm he
does it all single-handedly
coincidentally the blood dome animation
from 2018 is like an early version of
multiverses
morty has the ability to whip out a huge
hammer and yate enemies with it the
first time we saw this version of morty
was back in season one when a massive
marty uprising became a fight scene and
one of those mortys is a literal hammer
[Music]
one of marty's moves in game is a
temporal teleport to do this he uses
this controller it allows him to make a
backup of his life and then reload it
it's a reset seems harmless right in the
show he used it multiple times without
any problem the thing is things get dark
rick explains every time morty presses
that button he eliminates an alternate
version of himself every time you reset
the smell jessica's hair every time you
relive the satisfying fart that's how
many mortys you've incinerated you
greedy little junkie god
like all the other multiverses
characters marty has unique win and loss
animations we'll talk about the orange
juice soon when morty is defeated he'll
throw himself into a vat of acid but
this may not be as painful as it looks
in the show rick and morty do this
what kind of psycho his own grandson
yeah he's totally fine in there
this acid is fake fat a fake acid are
you dying of dementia and when it
splashed on a police officer he thought
he was immune and then went on tv to
demonstrate acid can't hurt him it
didn't go well for him and finally
marty's swan dive version of this is
when morty fakes his own death to please
an angry horde when winning marty will
chug down some orange juice which is
also his default emote he can be seen
regularly drinking orange juice in the
show yet this version of him chugging
straight from the carton is taken from
the episode where morty is given
gwendolyn a robot made for um how do i
say it pleasure marty stays in his room
for days and only comes out for
refreshment you'll never see orange
juice in the same way again ugh all
right back to back to back upstairs
let's move on from that it's possible to
see the fire attack in game and also a
rock wall too these are thanks to rings
marty wes in the show there are four
rings of elemental powers which combine
together to summon planeteena who marty
falls madly in love with fyi planetena
is also a reference to captain planet a
tv show from yesteryear about a
superhero environmentalist as it's rick
and morty things get heated now if
you're wondering how marty got those
rings he took out all the people who
owned them all in the name of love
now we can be together planet tina
morty's alter tire is president marty an
evil version of himself who became the
leader of the citadel a society created
solely from rick and morty's in the
season five finale he gave a chilling
speech with drink in hand but speeches
are for campaigning
now is the time for action
which became the menu select animation
oh and when this morty wins he'll sit in
his presidential chair and his loss
animation will result in a slow clap
both taken straight from the show
will la dee da hey that's mine morty can
summon a doorway portal mid-battle this
is a throwback to the time morty
accidentally started a war while trying
to get wine it turns out time in this
dimension narnia travels faster than
morty's homeworld which meant a nice
chap named hoovy who helped morty with
the wine returned home through the
portal to find time had passed so much
that his wife was no more and his feral
child declared war on morty this lasted
generations all because of that portal
one of morty's up attacks shoots lasers
which split into two snakes this is a
nod to the rattlestar riglactica episode
in which an astronaut snake bit morty
and thanks to his meddling though snakes
invented time travel and hunted down
rick and morty morty has a laser blaster
in hand in game this one was tough to
track down because basically he has a
lot of blasters in a lot of episodes in
the end i'd say it's this one from
season 2 episode 4 total rick fall when
marty has to decide which of his
memories is real and which of his family
members are fake figured it out rick the
parasites can only create pleasant
memories i know you're real because i
have a ton of bad memories with you when
standing completely still marty will
idle into this animation the classic
derp face morty he has this pose
regularly in the show when he has no
idea what to do next so i guess it's the
perfect idle animation i know this next
one's obvious but we're going for a full
house of animations morty can summon
rick's space cruiser it's in almost
every single episode of rick and morty
but you already knew that so let's move
on
marty will throw out a whip occasionally
which doesn't seem to fit with the rest
of his move set but yeah it's legit
during the multiplicity episode in
season 5 we were shown decoys of the
whole family and that broke out into
another war between the numerous decoys
during these fight scenes one of the
mortys has that whip which is a nod to
the energy whips in star trek not the
whip your mum has upstairs there are
other rick and morty references which
i'd like to pay homage to now the
cromulen stage with floating heads
around a giant speaker is from the get
schwifty episode in season two basically
earth was selected to take part in a
music competition by the crumblings and
only the winning planet got to stay in
one piece the cromulons have decided to
declare earth the final winner and bring
our musical reality show to a conclusion
goodbye
and that's where this awesome song was
born oh yeah
you gotta get schwifty have you ever
noticed this ring out animation in
multiverses
[Music]
the sunscreen this is from the time rick
and morty went to a wedding and ended up
having to go into hiding on a new planet
one of their choices was this place it
was perfect just like earth until the
sun came up
yep it was a planet where the sun
screams during daylight hours uh they
didn't choose to stay very long
so how did i do if i missed any please
let me know in the comments and i'll add
them to the next character breakdown
video a huge thanks to my discord and a
few rick and morty obsessives for
helping me track down the episodes i'm
adam you're awesome see you next time